[Music]
financial literacy is kind of bedrock to
any long-term change pretty much for
everybody but certainly for females the
world spends a lot of time talking about
the SDGs these are the sustainable
development goals mention all sorts of
goals health equality participation that
cannot be realized unless you have some
authority over resources you can know a
right but if you don't have a way of
getting that right or a bargaining
position then it's just an idea for
girls they begin to see themselves as
just an extended part of other people
they begin to define themselves as you
know doing household and quote domestic
activities they don't see themselves for
what they are which is vital economic
actors so the first thing the financial
literacy does is it says you're an
economic actor you're making economic
choices every single day with the tight
the way you use your time the way you
use scarce resources much of the work
that you do makes it possible for
someone else to do some other work so
just an identification financial
literacy also means building specific
capabilities being able to analyze
situations risk situations and
opportunity situations for example when
you're working with a population which
has never thought of themselves as being
economic contributors if you asked the
question well imagine that you're a girl
of 12 in domestic service what are the
scenarios
what were the times that you are in the
riskiest position and then people will
say well oh when you ask for your salary
because if they don't give it to you you
have no recourse you're on the street if
you ask a young Merritt for a young
married girl when you know how is it
she's going to choose a number and
timing of her children well the she's
not she's not unless she has some
bargaining position with her partner if
the partner has complete control of her
sexually and her fertility she has no
way of saying I don't want to have a
child now
or I want to wait or so her being able
to control some resources and not feel
completely dependent what happens often
is that young women women females are
working and they're earning but they are
not able they're trying to save but
they're turning over almost all of what
they make and their time to other people
so financial literacy makes them aware
of the fact that they are daily
supporting not only themselves but
others it also teaches real-world
Financial Inclusion skills what are
different kinds of savings what
different kinds of savings you need to
have you need to have emergency savings
because particularly for the poorest if
you don't have someone to turn to a
number if you don't have some money
aside in emergency then a young female
in particular is an immediate sexual
high sexual risk or she may need
emergency savings to help another family
member then there are longer-term
savings which are goal-oriented for
example saving up towards education we
have in our work something called the
cash flow tool and I remember in Haiti
after the earthquake we became aware
that there was a catastrophic level of
sexual violence against the girls the
mud and most of these households were
run by beleaguered women lean twos you
know it was a desperate situation the
programs that did exist were called
child-friendly spaces which lump boys
and girls together and ultimately in
most cases had older boys only were
unsafe places for girls the bathrooms
were put in places if the girls couldn't
get to safely and there was you know a
kind of they were like war zones so in
July after the earthquake we had a
workshop in Haiti and we started talking
about what age did a girl in Haiti need
to really understand not only her safety
but how to resource for herself safely
and we didn't previously put the age at
eight and one we had a 12 year old there
and she said no no it's six it's at six
girls need to know this information
we in that setting and we often do
brought out something called the cash
flow tool so we ask people to draw
pictures of several different types of
girls by age and by education and then
we ask them now list the places from
which such girls get money and we do get
money from little chores they get money
they're sometimes given and they're very
good savers so that's on one side and on
the other side there's a listing of and
what does this girl need to spend on and
they make that list as well and then we
say all right so what's the most
important source of the money and then
they circle that and what's the most
important item that on their budget it
takes the most money and they circle
that and then people begin to see that
there's an imbalance sometimes there are
she taking more money in than they need
to spend so we always say well what you
can save is the difference between what
you want and what you need so it's a
process of becoming very conscious not
only of your contributions but how you
can manage often in scarcity I think
it's valuable for anybody when you know
my children were growing up I couldn't
find a financial literacy course there
was a great book that says the Armen
wrote called what's that young broke and
fabulous and it was I thought it was
terrific because it would take real
scenarios that you actually faced you
have very little money but you really
need a car what are your real choices
and that's another thing that financial
literacy does it lays out reality based
scenarios it doesn't talk to use if
you're middle-aged and are making a big
salary and buying your first house it
outlines real scenarios of economic risk
in need and then it says in how would
you negotiate it
if you're a young poor female what you
have to do is very different than if
you're an older male just in theirs most
of the prescriptions for the older and
better off populations will have no
place with these girls then you have a
real conversation with the girls so what
will it really take for you to get
school supplies this year what will it
really take for the rent to be paid
without some one story from Kenya
introducing very simple budgeting one of
the girls we were working with came back
and said to her mentor this was the
first year basically I didn't have to go
out and sleep with my boyfriend without
a condom because we had enough money to
cover the rent in November which was
just before school fees were due those
are those that's how close the margins
are but you have to get down to that
level of reality and give and and one
thing more thing I want to say when you
have a sense of control over one part of
your life it extrapolates to another so
for example in South Africa one of my
colleagues did wonderful research Kelly
home and her associates and they they
introduced in the in the school setting
in South Africa which was also in the
highest HIV zone where again much higher
rates of HIV infection among females
than males and thought that financial
literacy would be core not just because
people need livelihoods but because it
would make information for instance
about HIV much more salient at the
beginning of the program the girls that
was girls and boys they were separated
for some sessions and together four
others were asked do you think of
yourself at being at any exceptional
risk for HIV and these were girls often
of you know 15 with a partner who was 25
years older in a zone with 25% HIV
prevalence and they would say no have
you been HIV tested no after several
months of financial literacy their
incomes hadn't changed their savings
hadn't changed but their idea that there
was some aspect of her life economically
that they could change so they were
asked do you have a financial goal and
that didn't mean you'd achieved it but
you had a goal the the the girls just
having a financial goal changed their
ability to realistically assess their
HIV risk if they had a partner ten years
older they thought hmm maybe I should
get a different partner they were much
more likely to get tested they saw a
scope that
information of just psychological
control and recognition immediately
translated into being able to mobilize
health information so it is where is
good health is always valued health
doesn't Drive economics as strongly as
economics drive health without economic
resources it's difficult for females
especially to make good health decisions
[Music]